Oh
Big Sky Country fields forever and
10,000 genetically pure bison think of
it as the Serengeti in America's
backyard and once finished it'll be the
largest wildlife park in the lower 48
we're putting together eventually about
a three and a half million acre reserve
this is also the area where Lewis and
Clark came through and saw enormous
densities in wildlife and so what we're
doing is bringing back the keystone
species and eventually they will run
free and while Meyers is one of hundreds
of donors who've committed more than 60
million dollars in the past decade to
create the American prairie reserve
among them
kandi Ayers Forest in John Mars former
PepsiCo CEO Roger and Rico and George
mate lish of Kelso & Co we can complete
this project for 450 to 500 million
dollars including an endowment to take
care of it forever and do it in about 20
or 25 years today
the preserve spans two hundred and forty
seven thousand acres plan over the next
several years by up an area the size of
Connecticut then work with the
government to protect it just like a
National Park to us that's the best way
to go an entrepreneurial private
approach to create something for a
public benefit without asking the
government to donate any money
we're basically buying the ranches as
they come available families who've been
ranching the area for generations are
not thrilled about their new neighbor
and the influx of wildlife our county
alone feeds 2.8 million people per year
and you take that out of production and
put bison on it
quite a dent in the food for the world
if they achieve their goals they want
everybody out here gone right now the
Prairie foundation is paying top dollar
for land they're outbid and everybody
person with the biggest checkbook is
going to own it is it right you know
that's the way it is but the APR is
determined to be a good neighbor
we're keeping up good fences so the
Bison don't negatively impact our
neighbors but we're also starting we
think our innovative ideas helping them
sell their beef into higher end higher
margin markets by being able to market
their beef as wildlife friendly because
they're in the region of the American
prairie reserve I sometimes think that
it to be a founder of yellowstone or
yosemite would be one of the greatest
thrills in my life and so there's the
opportunity to be the founder of what we
think will be one of the jewels of this
country eventually